we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
we got a voicemail from the eggman he
believes
that uh the so-called concept of freedom
of religion is bogus because it doesn't
apply to all religions equally
let's let the egg man say it himself
like only he can
hey dave and pat i think freedom of
religion is overrated
no i think freedom of religion shouldn't
be a thing anymore it's complete
it's totally subjective and this ban on
full-face
coverings in switzerland is a hundred
percent a good thing
sorry guys but i'm totally for it you
shouldn't be able to cover your entire
face in public
it's a safety problem in our country in
any country
yeah you can wear a mask for health
reasons of course here's the deal guys
people are using freedom of religion do
the most insane
things okay and it's not that they're
doing insane things they're refusing
other people to do and save things aka
spaghetti monster
satanism i have a religion that is not
acknowledged
by this country or by the world and i
don't get freedom of religion
i smoke marijuana for my religion it
harms no one right
illegal where i live how come some
people can cover their entire face
or do horrible things in the name their
religion
but i can't smoke a bowl when i come
home to bring my prayers up to god
because that's what my culture tells me
freedom of religion is freaking stupid
we have to stop it
it's going to cause tons more problems
in the future on this planet
shalom brother all right so there is the
egg man
shot out of a cannon with a principled
and defiant speech
supporting the face covering ban in
switzerland which we discussed yesterday
on the bonus show all right on today's
bonus show
we will talk about the fallout from the
harry and megan interview there's a
really interesting media story there
we will talk about the latest in the
george floyd case which is now
going to be delayed and we will talk
about a risk factor for kovid
not getting that much attention but it
correlates with
78 percent of those hospitalized
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get
instant access to the bonus show by
getting a membership at joinpakman.com
that's option number one
or becoming a patron at patreon.com
david pakman show that is option number
two
i will see you then